welcome to the click2deploy series where
we show you how
easy it is to deploy solutions from
google cloud marketplace
google cloud marketplace has been
focused on helping users
explore launch and manage production
grade solutions with just a few clicks
marketplace has an easy way to deploy
technical solutions
called click to deploy click to deploy
allows you to deploy virtual machines
and kubernetes solutions
on google compute engine easily
you can deploy a solution without having
to manually configure the software
virtual machine instance storage or
network settings
this helps you free up more time to
focus on building great products
you have the option to deploy solutions
like wordpress
lamp stack mongodb and apache cassandra
with just the click of a button just
search for the solution and select the
ones that meet your business needs
when you launch the deployment you can
either use the default configurations
or customize the configurations to meet
your project needs
so next time you're looking for a way to
quickly deploy your solution
check out google cloud marketplace to
learn more
check out cloud.google.com marketplace
[Music]